هناك قصة كبيرة أخرى وهي أننا
نتابع أه النفط بالطبع مع عدم
سفر أحد أه أثناء الوباء ، شهدت
أرامكو السعودية أكبر شركة نفط في العالم
انخفاضًا في أرباحها السنوية
بأكثر من 40 في المائة العام الماضي ،
ما الذي يخبرنا به ذلك عن العام
الذي كان وماذا
كنا؟  يمكن أن نتوقع في العام المقبل
أننا كنا في مؤتمر عبر الهاتف مع
مجموعة محدودة من المراسلين في الشرق الأوسط ،
أقصد ناصر الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركة أرامكو السعودية ويقول
إنني أشعر بالارتياح نوعًا ما لأن ذلك كان أسوأ
عام
في مجال الطاقة  مشاهد كونك
رئيسًا ومديرًا تنفيذيًا للشركة
وهذا بالتأكيد بخس
لأن
ما تتحدث عنه كان ليندا هو
أن الطلب كان أقل من 20
آه في الربع الثاني من عام 2020 في
ذروة الوباء
بشكل عام بانخفاض 10 للعام و
نتيجة لذلك ، إذا نظرت إلى
نتائج أرباح أرامكو السعودية التي انخفضت من
إلى 49 مليار دولار ، فهي أكبر
شركة نفط في العالم واحدة من
أكبر الشركات في العالم.
حقيقة لا تزال مربحة
ولكنها مكدسة مقابل 87 مليار
دولار سنويًا قبل
نوع من الضربة المزدوجة هنا ، هم في
اتفاقية أوبك بلس ، قررت المملكة العربية السعودية
دعم الأسعار عن طريق خفض الإنتاج
بمقدار مليون برميل أخرى يوميًا
وفبراير
ومارس  هذا يضر بعائداتهم
لأنهم لا يصدرون
نفس القدر من الصعوبة ، لذا
علينا التفكير في البطاقة الجامحة لأرامكو السعودية
وللمملكة
العربية السعودية بشكل عام
، فهي تقريبًا على أساس أسبوعي الآن
لدينا المتمردون الحوثيون
يشنون الهجمات من خلال  طائرات بدون طيار على
منشآت أرامكو السعودية النفطية ، كان
آخرها يوم الجمعة الماضي لمصفاة الرياض ،
رأينا ذلك في جدة على مدار
الشهرين الماضيين وفي
العام الماضي في الحزام الزيتي في
كعكة تطبيق rastanura بالمملكة العربية السعودية ، هذه هي المرافق التي  لقد
تعرضوا للضرب أو
أصيبوا بالفعل ، فلديهم دفاعات جيدة جدًا
ولكن
كل أسبوع في الأسبوع والأسبوع يتم
اختبارهم
بشكل منتظم لمنشآتهم
النفطية  على الرغم من أن الرئيس التنفيذي قال
إنهم موثوقون بنسبة 99.9 في المائة لا يزالون
يستخرجون هذا النفط من البلاد